agents we've recovered five of the
hostages taken in the attack on the
White House but we still have more to
bring home Cindy McAllister our former
eye in the sky was among the Personnel
that were taken from the castle agents
we need to get her
[Music]
back Cindy melster was raised in a
household with strong military ties and
was the youngest of six siblings with
five older brothers Cindy was one of the
boys and developed a keen passion for
gaming following her enlistment in the
Army she found her Niche within the
National Guard as a drone pilot after
the outbreak she would join The Joint
Task Force and due to her Excellence she
would quickly be recruited by the
division in this position she would
assist agents and scouting various
locations warning the Agents of lurking
threats and potential ambushes when the
Russian scientist fatali Treno emerged
once again this time on Coney Island
Cindy maneuvered a remote drone
collaborating with the division agents
to orchestrate jtf forces ensuring the
successful location and extraction of
Treno in the face of fierce resistance
from the Black Tusk she hacked into
their mortars turning their Weaponry
against them following the successful
extraction of Treno by the division
agents Cindy identify the remaining
Black Tusk operators currently Under
Siege by the cleanness her guidance
directed the agents to the heart of the
amusement park allowing them to
neutralize all hostile units but as the
agents removed the last of the opposing
forces the Drone was suddenly hacked by
the rogue agent Aaron
kenina before the Drone was destroyed
kenina sent his message to the agents
claiming that he will Contin to be one
step ahead of them following these
events Manny would pull Cindy
aside are you ready to talk about what
happened at Cony Island there's nothing
to talk about Manny I did what I had to
do to get the job done your agent is
back safe and sound mission accomplished
you used mortars and almost got everyone
killed I took the enemy's toys away from
them and we found out about keener's
involvement that's a win that's a war
crime you're going to take me to the ha
I'm worried about you Cindy I'm fine we
have work to do if we're going after
kener you're going to need a good drone
operator Kelo is going after kener
you're staying here until I know what
the hell to do with you
you're not my supervisor you don't get
to make that call you're right no one is
really in charge but you're my friend
and I'm worried about you I want you to
talk to Dr Billings you think I'm crazy
I think you've had to disconnect from
the daily horror we see to survive it
and starting to change you in ways that
make me concerned and if this doctor
clears me can I go to New York if Mitch
says you're good to go I won't stop you
deal Cindy would head off to see Dr
Mitchell Billings and attempt to gain
approval joint Kelo in New York
City how you doing Cindy oh just great
you know all sunshine and rainbows it's
like life is so beautiful it's perpetual
summer you don't have to worry about
your unemployed drone operator how do
you think I'm doing disappointed and
tired so you talked to Dr Billings I
thought those meetings were confidential
he didn't tell me anything he wasn't
supposed to I know you I know your tired
face
I know you must be disappointed and
you're still here so he clearly did not
give you permission to go to New York
with Kelso so what are you a detective
now too what were you bored and needed
another job how can I help you can't
help I'm broken and everything I
normally do to forget I'm broken I'm not
allowed to do anymore so here we are you
need a hobby no I don't you need to
spend some time with real people get get
out from behind the screen go touch some
grass or help Mel with a farm the only
farming I've done is crypto that's great
you've already got Farm experience no
Manny that's not what it means it never
mind I guess I could give it a
try Cindy I need your help with
something good to see you too how was
your summer mine was great thanks sorry
you're right how are you you know the
usual trying to stay positive in the
face of impending disaster we trying to
grow tomatoes in the fall this seems
like it might be a mistake your what
Manny you want to update
Kelo I need to get back to the castle
what the hell is going on what's wrong
with Cindy nothing is wrong she just
needed to take a break but we need her
she's our Eye in the Sky if Paul's
reports are correct you've gotten pretty
good at being the eye in the sky I'm not
as good as Cindy and I can't be in the
field if I'm doing recon that's true not
a very good reason to keep Cindy on Farm
Duty Farm Duty I thought that was a joke
now wait until you try the tilapia and
tomato salad I promise you mari's
cooking is no
joke Mari who the [__] is
Mari so Cindy has now been reassigned to
the castle sentiment many thinks that
sometime away from computer monitors
will do us some good unfortunately poor
Kelo who's been away in New York she has
missed a lot of what's been going on in
DC
Cindy I'd like you to meet your newest
recruit Wall-E nice to meet you Wall-E
any special skills I should know about
for job placement are you serious yes
okay um engineer computers helped run a
nuclear power plant for the last 6
months so infrastructure and power how
are you at puzzles great love them the
more impossible to solve the better I
recovered this encrypted file from a
hunter drone haven't been able to break
the encryption maybe you could take AEP
dab at it oh sure is that my job now if
you can crack the encryption sweet I was
a little worried you were going to put
me to work shucking corn or some
[__] you're an engineer if you're
going into food production I'd put you
on the aquaponic system you got a fish
farm we
do you should be resting this is my job
go do your
job go get our people back Manny if
you're not going to do that you're not
the man I thought you were I love
you I love you too go do your job before
it's too
late Manny Manny come in this is Agent
Johnson I've got to lead on the
recruiter this is Manny good to hear
from you agent Johnson it's been a while
honestly I thought you were dead I get
that a lot was following up on a lead
about the Arnolds and got word the
recruiter was moving Vic to a secure
location that's great at least we know
they're still alive the rumors are true
Sova is putting them to work she's not
interested in assassinating them so much
as what they can do for her I'm not sure
which is worse she thinks she can turn
our people to her side and that it might
be working
agent get ready we have a
lead agent Johnson has found a lead on
Cindy's whereabouts he has traed her to
the East Mall
District the first location Johnson SS
the agents to is the Metro ruins there
are reports Cindy has been spotted
nearby agents roll up to the control
point and are immediately greeted by
hordes of Black Tusk soldiers
fortunately some much needed help would
come along as the jtf would assist in
gaining control of the compound
the agents would eventually clear out
the Hostile presence including the
elimination of Two Black Tusk leaders
and this is when agent Johnson would
provide an update on Cindy's
position system
react Black Tusk are moving down
Independence Avenue
Southwest well done pull through nice
work agent track the Black Tusk movement
down to a large building complex in the
northeastern side of the district after
killing a handful of guards on the
street they make their way into the
building fighting through they come
across one of the first black dusk
leaders on site but they wouldn't find
as much of a challenge as they steamed
forward after killing what seemed like
an infinite wave of hostiles the final
Target would eventually make themselves
known but because the agents spent far
too much time fluffing around or getting
lost the enemy Target would eventually
end up leaving their fortified position
position and coming to them but this
wouldn't help them much they took no
time dealing with them and once
eliminated Johnson would once again be H
over the
coms taking
fire hostile radio
intercepted we need someone more
programming experience at the solar farm
I'm just a drone operator Cindy you not
just a drone operator you're so much
more than that at least you could be I
see your potential please don't diminish
your
talent agent get to the solar farm Sova
is trying to manipulate Cindy lattery
won't work with her she's smarter than
[Music]
that agents quickly made their way over
to the solar farm in hopes that they
would be able to intercept the Black
Tusk before they once again move on with
Cindy in a calculated and coordinated
assault the agent stormed the control
Point engaging in a firefight against
the entrenched black task forces but
with jtf backup the agents were able to
push through the way of a Black Tusk
that continued to trickle out of the
facility after removing the leader and
then defending the site from a heavy
push back by the Black Tusk attempting
to reclaim the site the agents once
again hear from
Johnson bomb over
go agent cdy spotting at the Museum of
native peoples hopefully the water's
still on I used to love that
place making their way over to the
museum just slightly south of their
position the agents track a unit of
Black Tusk who are suspected of holding
Cindy after clearing the guards out
front they are send several floors into
the building where they are met by
another huge group of hos hle soldiers
making the way to the roof they continue
to take down members of this Black Tusk
unit until eventually the leader would
make himself
known upon elimination Johnson would
update the agents on the next
[Music]
location agent we've located Cindy
mallister she's at the Aaron Space
Museum
I don't know we took a wants with her
but Cindy is one of us she can't be
turned it was clear that the agents had
caught up with them as there were vast
numbers of elite Black Tusk that were
spewing out from an entranceway located
under the compound it's at this point
that I must apologize to a Mr stick for
not being able to assist based on your
username I'd say there likely wouldn't
be a lot in the way of conversations we
could have that would be appropriate for
YouTube the agents continued to push
through the facility climbing up into
different levels clearing wave after
wave in some areas the agents felt that
their more defensive style of build
Choice was just feeling a little bit
slow with other areas feeling like they
were just running around in
circles to need a bucket wait what did
he
say to need a bucket yeah I'm just going
to assume that I'm hearing that wrong
continuing to push through the onslaught
of Black Tusk that would being thrown at
them they would eventually come across
several of the leaders that have
bunkered down throughout the facility
once the final leader had been dropped
jtf would move in and rescue Cindy
taking her back to the
castle thanks for the rescue agent it's
super weird to be on this side of the
mission glad you're safe Cindy agent
meet us back at the
castle
thanks for the rescue agent I know you
must think of me as silly Cindy the
Drone operator and sometimes trigger
happy mortar operator but I promise I
like my new job better it's a better fit
so if you need someone to recruit I'm
your
recruiter Cindy's new job is finding
roles for people new to the castle
settlement so yes as she was trolling us
there she technically is the recruiter
in the recruitment section of the castle
sediment but not the actual Hunter
recruit are we're looking for or is she
no I I really don't think she
is Cindy it's good to have you back
please don't hug me you look like you're
going to hug me are you okay I've been
better I've been
worse I'm ready to get back to work and
pretend this [__] never happened doc
Billings won't be happy but I'm good
thank you while I could use your help
we've been having issues with the mobile
shade server what kind of issues I I
have no idea the computer thing was
never really my area I'll talk to Wally
it really is good to see you you too
Manny so Cindy was our drone operator
she would make some questionable calls
and it was discovered that she wasn't
coping with everything going on and
needed to step down and take on some
different
responsibilities Cindy would then be
captured as part of the Black Tusk
attack and Natalia would try to sway her
to work on other systems however the
agents were able to track her down with
the help of agent Johnson and bring her
home nothing huge to pull apart here
like I mentioned in the other video I
really don't trust agent Johnson and how
he has suddenly turned up but I suspect
we'll hear more about him later
something that was mentioned at the
start of this rescue and then once again
at the end was the problems they seem to
be having with a mobile shd
server hey agent it's Wall-E agent
Johnson found a lead on Cindy good thing
the network is stable the mobile shade
server has been a little touchy the
mobile shd server is the reason we were
quickly able to bounce back after the
attack on the White House
Natalia had also attacked one of the shd
cores and then taken down the division
Network this means that none of the
agent technology would work no skills no
HUD no communication and no ISAC however
we had the mobile shd
server it's unclear how many of them we
have but the network has gone down a
couple of times now because of attacks
and without the mobile server the agents
would have been severely hinded so while
this seems like something minor right
now I believe the mobile server issues
could lead to something larger much
later
on I feel like I'm apologizing for being
late every second video so I think I'm
going to stop doing that now if you're
still watching my videos by now you've
probably learned to expect it I'm no
good at just pumping out videos quickly
I need to be in the right frame of mind
and I prefer to triple check everything
I'm talking about as well as playing
through several times before I can even
start writing about it so there it is
the rescue of Cindy which I really think
is just small leading to what could be
picking up traction like later on in my
next video I want to run through the
coms that can be discovered while
playing through the Paradise Lost
incursion no I haven't been able to play
it myself yet I'm still finding some
more players on PC that can work around
my terrible time zone but I'll explain
all of this soon thank you very much for
watching and extremist MS extremer
[Music]
[Applause]
remedia
[Music]
n